pop
[Musique]
jégo
oui moi aussi j'étais là pourquoi
toujours derrière moi parce que je pense
toujours à toi ça va réparer
alors à m vas-y andré on voit le plus
basque
[Musique]
j'ai voulu passer par doivent à ce
qu'elle joue bien quand même
le fait que ce serait oui moi aussi
j'étais là pourquoi toujours derrière
nous
parce que je pense toujours à toi
détrôné du cri'art doha
[Musique]
on s'est trouvés
rien n'est perdu nous sommes est perdu
on va aussi trouver d'autre part là j'ai
chanté trop tôt tu toi pour que tu fais
ça ne peut pas attendre ta peau la
caisse claire parce que c'est dans les
trucs temps tu t'appelles ça fait mouche
comme en fait foi j'ai pas du tout de
retour j'en parle zinc et images en
temps parce qu'elle chante vraiment ce
que je disais en ruines
je crois que ça va se terminer en dur de
candice est mauvais
rien n'est perdu nous sommes est perdu
on va le prouver
[Musique]
e
à l'entrée pourquoi tout ça bien voix
parce que je trouve ça viendra à vrai
dire ces prochains plein pourquoi
faut-il que champlain parce qu'il faut
bien pas me l'a dit on c'est trop
rien n'est perdu tout seul et perdu en
valeur
[Musique]